c'est le charme de cette émission
j'aurais vu jouer star tient assis côte
à côte avec maurice matte et retirez
vous c'est pour me c'est pour moi
pouvait faire comme ça il y au
immortaliser ce moment deux immortels
willow mais comment ça va tuer savoir
merci tu connais maurice donnant j'ai
découvert la valeur sur les concours
grand résistant il s'est battu contre
les nazis pendant la guerre
actuelle oui et lui il y aura une autre
forme de résistance vous êtes du rap je
suis du rapport a baissé bien vous aimez
bien le terme rappeuse pour les filles
j'ai osé ne pas oser le demander non
c'est rapière qu'il faudrait dix
ça vous plaît maurice côté
ça me surprend un peu mais j parce que
j'ai pas très bien compris les paroles
c'est pour ça
c'est dans ma benz benz vans et dans une
mercedes il ya fait journée l'oise l'a1
et when the watch
il va nous prendre pour des beatniks
qu'on veut c'est dans le dico c'est quoi
le féminin de beatniks d'ailleurs vite
niktamère bien
donc jo et bonsoir vous êtes ici pour un
livre qui s'appelle mauvaise réputation
votre autobiographie écrite en
collaboration avec philippe manoeuvre
rédacteur en chef de rock & folk et
publié par laurent chollet chez
flammarion voilà vous avez pris un
rockeur pour écrire une histoire de
rappeur est ce que c'est pas un peu
bizarre ça mais bon je prends moi je
crois que je suis pas de rock mais je
suis un peu rock'n'roll quoi qu'il
arrive mais on a su qu'on a su se
trouver là dessus là au début l'idée de
raconter votre vie ça vous ça vous
saouler quand même non bah ouais ouais
tu dois savoir on peut distinguer ce que
en général c'est un exercice que je
pratique pas trop quoi ouais au départ
j'étais un peu réticent
on a on a on n'a pas souvent l'occasion
d'être protagoniste et spectateurs à la
fois là j'ai pu être un peu spectateur
du truc quoi j'ai pu avoir le recul de
ça c'est ce qui m'a plu un peu aussi
quoi alors on commence au début tu dis
nous sommes une vraie famille il ya ton
père ta mère et toi tes parents se sont
rencontrés aux antilles ton père
entraînait ta mère en france la france
et l eldorado pour les antillais loin
c'était la génération qui pensaient que
en france bon ben voilà il sera rien
enfin déjà à mon avis ils s'attendaient
à voir un statut un statut qui n'ont pas
eu ce coin et puis puis voilà quoi ils y
allaient pour aller travailler ainsi de
suite quoi
à ton père très séducteur à mon père
vraiment
mon père est un charbon avec les yeux
gris enfin genre espèce de bellâtre quoi
il se plaisait beaucoup à lui-même mais
surtout aux femmes quand il la trompe
ouais enfin il s'amuserait la pauvre un
étudie la dernière image que j'ai de mes
parents sand c'est le en train de se
taper dessus ouais l'époque taqwa 3 4
ans ouais dans ces eaux là quoi ça
marque ouais
mais bon moi avec le temps j'ai réussir
un peu à évacuer tout ce à quoi je le
sais ça reste forcément quoi c'est comme
un sac à dos l'histoire
un clash pas quoi mais moi je crois que
du tout ça j'ai réussi à en faire des
choses au final c'est sûr que j'ai envie
de dire dans ce niveau là quoi c'est que
malgré le cursus en ont donné bon ben je
verrais jamais réalisé
c'est ce qui est le mot passion
et ainsi de suite alors tes parents
divorcent et ton père magouille pour
avoir ta garde tu la vois une fois c'est
le jour de tes seins quand elle est
venue apporter des cadeaux mais tempère
les jettent à la poubelle ou alors il ne
visait en fait devenir files r chaque
fois de manière continue tacle je crois
que c'est bien après j'ai su qu'elle
venait tous les ont fait trois
équipiers se prenait un mur à chaque
fois quoi elle elle dit c'est mon fils
j'ai droit de le voir bah ouais ce qui
est ce que vous pouvez pour légitimement
+1 et lui dis dégage
la [ __ ] là enfin d'après lui c'était
une manière d'interférer par rapport à
l'éducation qu'il avait l'impression de
me donner quoi et puis en plus moi pas
les gamins qu'on pose des questions
pourquoi pourquoi les autres on nettoie
pas
tu arrive enfin
vit dans une cité dont tu te rends chez
les autres tu vois un cadre familial
tout ça que tu as pas chez toi donc à
préparer des questions tu te poses et
puis j'ai des questions qui se posent à
ces jeunes quoi donc un moment donné
comme en face en plus ya pas de dialogue
donc tu trouves un peu des réponses qui
seul est
jamais évident quoi il a dit qu'elle
était morte à un moment à me redonner
ouais ouais mais je pense qu'à mon avis
là dessus le faire genre fous moi la
paix il m'aurait dit fou moi la paix où
elle est morte serait thème la même pour
lui quoi mais comment il peut être aussi
dur de perdre je tablerais comme j'étais
pas l'enfant du placard non plus
mais bah je sais pas non mais je pense
que ça moi les circonstances atténuantes
que je lui trouve c'est que
il vient d'un monde rural où il a dû se
battre lui pour aller à l'école alors
que voulait le faire travailler direct
les failles qui ramène de la thune et
puis qu'il n'était pas très tendre avec
lui non plus quoi moi j'ai vu ma
grand-mère à côté paternel une fois
c est ma pas l'épée comme un bestion
quoi enfin et menthe et sur son perron
et puis tout le monde s'affaire autour
raconté qu'elle regardait tout de suite
c'était donc je peux imaginer un peu le
contexte aussi dans lequel lui a dû
grandir d'après
baïla il circo un peu démuni face à moi
voilà enfin puis bon
lycée il a passé son enfance aux
antilles on se retrouve en france
moi j'ai je vais à l'école enfin je
rencontre des gens elles les moeurs sont
pas les mêmes quoi donc et lui il le
sent pas trop quoi il est très dur par
exemple il vous achète rien du tout donc
vous êtes obligé de jours et dès l'âge
de wau enfin le peu le petit fed a
l'impression de faire alors que bon on
n'en est plus là quoi je veux dire comme
tout le monde le sait on a dans une
certaine société de consommation à
partir en beauté impose pas un
téléviseur chez toi et que je parte à
13,13 10 13 ans tu as certainement vie
par rapport à tout ça et que bon ben
voilà il est très dur il ya l'histoire
du là par un jury blesse en lapin avec
sa voiture on verra mais ne l'a pas
blessé à la maison une diorite
commencent à s'intéresser aux lapins
d'arrivée j'ai une peur à la basse
jamais une vie d'animaux chez moi enfin
même approché avec leur des chiens dans
la rue enfin j'étais très donc je me
suis attaché au truc puisqu'il l'a
soigné on l'a gardé pendant une semaine
ou deux mois je dois avoir une dizaine
d'années quoi donc un moment donné c'est
le lapin machin enfin au départ chose à
acheter puis après c'était mon lapin
lapin bien dimanche
ça amène le lapin moi je l'amène tac de
coupes touchent derrière le crâne et os
pour y finir à la casserole et puis tu
es obligé de manger quoi voilà quoi donc
lui lui comme jette alors quoi il est il
a grandi dans un contexte où il y avait
des animaux machin que j'étais coutumes
et du fais quoi moi c'était enfin 93 je
veux dire toi c'était un animal
domestique pour lui c'était de la bouffe
ouais ouais voilà ouais en fait je ne me
suis pas rendu compte qu'ils étaient en
train d'agresser quoi
c'est marrant
mais moi j'en rigole aujourd'hui en juin
ça doit être vrai en fait non mais le
truc c'est que moi je me suis rendu
compte du côté burlesque de la situation
là on l'a on le raconte en quoi mes mais
sinon s'il est resté dans un coin me
disent on est curieux quand même assez
curieux quand tu as été élevé sur le
thème n'est pas une bonzesse quoi
entre autres comme à l'armée un peu
c'est un rappel l'armée après 1 et pas
de faiblesse et pas tu vois c'est à dire
que tu es dans un contexte on ne
communique pas trop
dw affectif c'est zéro
le seul endroit où tp n'a finalement
c'est l'école quoi parce que la tombe
est en fait c'est une fois que je passe
au chai de la porte parce que à un
moment donné tu développes une faculté à
évacuer enfin moi de chanter tu vois
j'ai évacué quoi c'est bien bon après
l'école c'est assez particulier parce
que on se devait d'avoir une blouse
quand j'en parle à mon père et miséreux
des mes retours en forme achetés dans
les règles et stylos et les machins lait
caillé est est bon le reste c'est bon
gars savent donc moi j'avais pour
feinter je voulais qu une veste de
pyjama en fait je me mettais une jambe
dans le dos tout le temps sans m'en
rendre compte quoi donc s'était jamais
évident koala un jour tu te fais choper
par les flics parce que je suis parce
que tu as quitte à piquer ton père vient
commissariat it mais une rouste essais
les flics qui sont obligés de calme et
on perd ils ont arrêté monsieur arrêtez
de le battre ouais enfin grosso modo
s'était fait ça chez vous mais pas ici
quoi tac en fait ben on était une bande
de gamins j'avais volé chez ces
conneries là on vers la tchéquie
retourné il ya de la neige
c'est même par l'ars engagés de la loire
et on était
un petit groupe de niaré
moment de sortir du magasin mais glace
et puis c'est une ironie qu il a attrapé
deux points que les pieds l'autre avec
une main à partager bon il y avait moi
dont nous quoi la maison c'était la
ceinture d'abord le bout en cuir et
ensuite le
la boucle ouais mais ouais 13 antilles s
à 1
c c'est culturel ça va sentir chez nous
vous êtes partisan de cette éducation à
la dure pour les enfants vont pas
d'exagération
quand même
sur les testicules non pas d'exagération
patchou ce cruel mais il est certain que
petit châtiments physiques
mais mais c'est vrai
la paire de gifles c'est pas mauvais du
tout
non c'est vrai écouter ça simplement sur
l'enfant celui des sentiments qui a une
autorité bah oui là c'était le cas avec
dieu et c'est tout me voyez le résultat
voilà alors joey l'adolescence une vie
un peu de merde a fini fait de la colle
à fumer des pétards à piquer tout va
vite une partie une demi heure pour
manger en plus tous les mois
et la région c'est la révélation la
claque du hip hop des américains qui
break au trocadéro je crois que wes et
si en fait c'est une eau sorties sur
paris c'était pour pas grand chose à
l'époque où on est mieux dans sa cour
pour une fois on a vu quelque chose car
les jeux qu'on défi et voilà donc en
fait foi que c'est pas nous qui avons
c'est le truc qui nous est tombé dessus
puisque à partir du jura s'est plus
jamais arrêter voix c'est l'acte a
rencontré bruno lopes futur kool shen en
fait il habitait de l'autre côté du
boulevard et
voilà un beau jour par le biais de sa
juste au monde va lui il avait un poste
pas nous
voilà c'est tout simplement que c'était
juste que ça quoi voilà après tu raconte
la naissance d'ntm le soir du premier
concert tu dis tout vient naturellement
tu trouve tout de suite tes trucs les
jeux de scène l'écrit bah ça faisait 72
ans qui était sous acide donc oui très
on se pose pas trop de questions quand
même ça c'est comme
comme quand on voit la scène quoi
tu dis diva de la scène j'aperçois
l'infini bah ouais je lève une fois puis
après j'ai des revues quoi après j'ai
après tu cours après quoi
c'est à dire mais si tu veux surtout que
c'est un contexte assez particulier
parce qu'on fait
j'étais avec kool shen et djs à l'époque
est bon nous on écrivait des textes
enfin c'était vraiment la petite réunion
chez chez ace
on était dans notre microcosme on
pensait jamais sortir on faisait des
tags pas accident enfin on allait tomber
sur une personne qui commence à nous
dire que
rap et enfin écrire c'est réservé à une
élite nous à ce moment là on le prenait
déjà pour un abruti donc forcément on
s'est dit bah on va essayer puis si on
essaye prendre une chaise quoi parce que
leurs besoins puis de là on écrit des
trucs mais qui en fait qu'on a trait aux
graffitis quoi voilà qui raconte ce
qu'on fait en fin de phase on va
commencer comme ça et je crois qu'on
sait pas faire autre chose en fait quoi
puisque les par une mauvaise chose qu'on
puisqu'en fait il a toujours fait part
par esprit de challenge et surtout pour
se faire plaisir quoi alors vous qui
écrivez un livre tiré des jardins où
vous dites que l'affaissement culturelle
commence avec le rap et le tag voilà
vous avez en face de vous un un rappeur
tiger voulait qui me saute dessus
n'allait pas marcher non
non mais c'est vrai que bon on aime bien
l'entendre les bien mais c'est pas du
tout à mes yeux
la culture moderne d'aujourd'hui mais
c'est tout à fait intéressant par
ailleurs c'est le doit pas aimer ce que
je fais j'aime pas ce qu'il fait bon
passer la main quand même je fais pas on
va pas faire une guerre lasse et aux
ballades mais c'est vrai je ne vois pas
d'avenir à sa tentative disons pour être
gentil bas pourtant cela fait plus de
vingt ans que ça dure comme
je crois que c'est elodie pompiers plus
grand des votants 20 ans ouais bah si
vous voulez encore la fin du sinaï en a
plein d'autres derrière moi donc à mon
avis c'est vous qui allez avoir un
problème et puis en plus le truc je
crois que je le trouve bon vous rendez
pas trop content c'est qu'en fait c'est
très adapté à des gens comme nous qui à
la base j'ai pas prononcé il suffit
celui là enfin il ya besoin de rien
comme pas de musique de ne même pas de
musique pour rapper ya pas forcément non
plus besoin de musique pour tailler il
faut juste être un peu klepto enfin je
veux dire c'est très adapté quoi à des
gens qui tient à un moment donné ont
envie de s'exprimer ou envie de bouger
ou envie de voyager sans se déplacer
ainsi de suite c'est très adapté c'est
très contemporain de toute façon qu'un
doigt des messins n'ont pas cette année
les gens comme nous nous sommes quand
même tous un peu pareil mais l'exercice
avec des goûts différents non mais moi
je parle mais non il ya un statut social
c'est à dire que moi moi ont donné mon
seul tout seul petit plaisir qu'on
chantait de la cité c'était d'aller sur
paris
aux pratiques et l'école du mépris c'est
nous méprisait donc on rester chez nous
et par le biais de ça on arrive à avoir
nagé en reste entre nous à faire notre
truc pourtant je suis pas je suis pas
quelqu'un de communautariste ou autre
mais ça nous a fait voyager puis et puis
prenez aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui très fermé ben ouais c'est
pas à moi de vous le dire ça parce que
c'est pas nous qui étions mis les
prisons quoi on subissait le mépris ce
qu'imaginent mais m'intéresse beaucoup
quelques nouveaux voisins c'est ceci
c'est son vocabulaire
il un vocabulaire à deux niveaux
et vous on comprend qu'ils fassent des
textes parce que d'abord le mot qu'ils
emploient le plus souvent d'où viendront
ces trucs ouais truc qui sert à tout
voilà et j'en ai d'autres séries dans
mes sites
c'est une chose au fond truc scellement
chose qui dise 1 et puis à côté de ça
des gays
dimon son pass avant mais qui sort déjà
d'un niveau d'un livre de langage assez
au contexte
évacuer micro causse
à sillery
maurice il serait temps qu'ils se
rendent compte que le rap fait aussi
évoluer la langue française et les et
laissez les slameurs sont des gens qui
maîtrisent aussi la langue si vous aviez
entendu l'autre jour quand corps malade
vous auriez été épaté par sa dextérité
dans l'écriture
et voilà quoi il y avait un garçon avec
qui j'avais dialoguer c'était un rappeur
gay dany brillant non ça
c'est quelqu'un qui sait dès qu'ils
m'appellent plus bigame et kiev qui a
une célébrité certaines un jeune noir
qui est très bien trouva son venir voler
sa salle est de ceux-là entre
concessionnaires oui c'est ça
il est criant comme s'est pas émoussée
solaire donc si cela il quoi il est
réglé bien comme pas l'intérêt si tu les
gens arrivent à six missiles dont mois
après les acrobates linguistique outre
puisque sans consacre bat linguistique
ça plaira maurice druon savoie y est
formidable joey attendait bon alors
après on continue le livre donc jo et
raconte son coup de foudre avec béatrice
dalle vous dit béatrice la ferrari des
gonzesses et quand vous la rencontrez
vous dites je nage dans le bonheur non
ça se passe soit 1 s'adresse bien enfin
moi j'ai une manière un peu plus
organique de parler parce que manoeuvre
après ça c'est ça c'est du malheur je
n'ai pas au bonheur mais
les cigarettes piéger c'est toi ou c'est
de manoeuvre seynoise un
problème tu dis c'est que vous êtes
devenu rapidement plus complices que cam
en quoi
mais c'est quoi cette phrase qui dit le
bois et la splendeur durée quand le
monde est à l'endroit mais nous on se
mettait dans la tête à l'envers pour
pouvoir marcher droit justement pas mal
ouais un jour c'est là un peu trop loin
et là tu dis c'est devenu moins drôle
quoi bah ouais on a le problème si mal
c'est qu'on a ce côté enfin elle com -
quoi donc tous confondus ce côté
jusqu'au boutiste 1
forcément
ça peut nous desservir aussi quoi vous
êtes un peu brûlé les ailes tous les
deux quoi mais on se faisant du bien
ouais vit une vraie passion l'un pour
l'autre non ouais c'est la merde ça
s'arrête inizan way
la rupture avec kool shen
cantons contre vient d'une cité on a
tous cette envie en eau des d'en sortir
surtout de se créer son contexte de
sortir un peu de tout ça même si les
façons de portant soir je dirais quand
on a grandi à une cité on ne peut pas
changer at sur quelque chose qui reste
gênant peut on peut essayer de parler
autrement de maquiller pousse à toujours
il ya toujours une espèce d'acuité qui
reste en panne ya plein de choses quoi
et moi j'ai eu l'impression que contient
la machine arrière c'est à dire que nos
habitants d'une cité nuit dans une
résidence et que abandonné
il avait un petit complexe au niveau de
ce à quoi ouais alors que enfin pour moi
ça jamais été de médailles quoi
un jour été a dit j'ai envie d'arrêter
j'ai une vie de famille je veux voir ma
meuf je ne vois jamais mais
bah ouais il me dit ça au moment où moi
moi là la fille avec qui je suis donc à
moore
grâce à elle je dors en semi liberté et
puis tout le monde me regarde comme
fonctionne comme une bruch donc doit que
je suis demandé est-ce qu'ils habitent
en australie ou en france quoi parce que
il est quand même au courant ce qui va
arriver que qui viennent me je comprends
qu'il a envie aussi d'avoir une vie à
côté parce que il en avait une de toute
façon quoi qu'il arrive juste à mon avis
ça c'était
s'était pas vraiment la libye qui fait
la raison je pense que un monde il
aurait peut-être pu être plus fondue
connaît surtout qu'en plus la veille on
se parle au téléphone est en fait c'est
on se voit demain pour voir ce qu'on va
faire pour le prochain album et du jour
au lendemain le mec me sors j'ai envie
d'arrêter moi ça fait 15 ans que je fais
ça à un moment donné tu ne sais plus
faire que ça et puis de toute façon
c'est à la base
moi je reproche pas le fait qu'on a
envie d'avoir une vie à côté mes en
train de vivre une aventure on n'a rien
demandé on tomber là dedans par exient
dont
on remplit des stades ont enfin on n'a
jamais demandé tout ça ce qui est
intéressant dans le bouquin c'est de
voir comment vous complétez tous les
deux tirs que lui il avait ses petits
cahiers et les créditer bien ces petits
trucs biens propres ça tu foutais le feu
sur scène ouais ouais ouais ouais il
faut pas comparer sur ça ça mais c'est
vrai que les vaches n'ont plus de
l'artiste un coin voilà dire que
ouais lilas il a besoin de savoir où il
va alors que moi
j'arrive encore à aujourd'hui aviron
quant au jour le jour quoi alors que lui
mais ça paraît que ça paraît impossible
quoi pour lui aujourd'hui tu as une vie
de famille toi ouais il va comment
mathis alors il vaut mieux au mur si ça
va il a l'humour ça va mieux que ce
matin ouais merci
[Applaudissements]
publié chez flammarion
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu